[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild hallo Leute kleine Warnung heute
wird's makaber heute wird sehr makaber
ja aber so richtig herzlich willkommen
zu einer ganz besonderen soap opera eine
Seifenoper im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
um genauer zu sein ein italienischen
Seifenoper und wie es sich für eine
ordentliche italienische Oper gehört mit
jeder Menge Tragik und natürlich Seife
und Schokokeksen aber keine veganen
Schokokekse nee definitiv nicht also
wobei ich mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher
bin ob Schokokekse wirklich so ein
typisches Thema für italienische Opern
sind da war ich zu wenig in
italienischen Opern ja ich glaube da
geht's eh um Sachen wie Liebe
Schicksal ja davon haben wir heute auf
alle Fälle jede Menge und eine
Opernsängerin die ist auch am Start aber
keine Sorge sie wird nicht singen und
wir auch nicht ja sie wird leider
sterben und nicht nur
sie okay Mirko genug gespoilert wir
fangen mal an ich bin Tony haer und ich
bin Mirko kimir hallo wir erzählen euch
heute die Geschichte von
leonardaanuli habt ihr was zum Knabbern
bereit sehr gut dann stellt es besser
jetzt mal zur Seite denn das ist keine
Story die man beim Essen hören will
vorab noch ein Hinweis wir haben die
Geschichte gründlich recherchiert aber
viele Details insbesondere der
Lebensgeschichte von Leonarda die sind
unklar oder werden widersprüchlich
erzählt eine der wichtigsten Quellen ist
außerdem ihre Autobiografie und dass die
wirklich objektiv ist das kann man dann
doch bezweifeln aber zumindest leonardas
taten die sind gut
dokumentiert
1893 montella Italien Mariano canchuli
ist verliebt unglücklich verliebt seine
Angebetete Emilia Marano zeigt ihm die
kalte Schulter doch chanchuli ist nicht
bereit diese Zurückweisung hinzunehmen
er will sich holen was er nicht haben
kann er will sich rächen er will seine
vermeintlich gekränkte Ehre
wiederherstellen und vergewaltigt die
junge Frau Emilia ist jung und
unerfahren und nach allem was wir wissen
eine unschuldige und ahnungslose Seele
sie begreift nicht was ihr wiederfahren
ist doch sie ahnt dass es eine Sünde war
möglicherweise Ihre eigene trägt sie
nicht als Frau den Makel der
Erbsünde ist nicht die Frau immer schuld
ist sie es nicht die den Mann zur Sünde
verführt okay hier nicht vergessen wir
befinden uns im streng katholischen
Italien des aus en 19 Jahrhunderts da
ist niemand an den sie sich wenden
könnte niemand der ihr sagen würde du
hast nicht den Hauch einer Schuld du
bist das Opfer eines Verbrechens und der
einzige der dafür verantwortlich ist das
ist der Vergewaltiger der Täter aber
Emilia schweigt doch als ihr Bauch zu
wachsen beginnt stellt ihre Familie sie
zur Rede und die nun eindeutig
Schwangere Emilia erzählt die ganze
Geschichte die Familie beschließt den
Täter zur Verantwortung zu Zehen klingt
erstmal gut aber sie verstehen darunter
etwas anderes als man heute denken würde
ja denn sie zwingen Mariano und Emilia
zur Heirat das Mädchen muss also ihren
Vergewaltiger heiraten und der geht
nicht nur straffrei aus nee er bekommt
auch noch die Frau auf die er es sowieso
abgesehen hatte und das ist einfach
ekelhaft aber genauso kommt es leider
die beiden heiraten und am 18 April 1894
wird ein Mädchen geboren Leonarda
Emilia hasst ihre Tochter vom ersten Tag
an sie kann ihr nicht vergeben was
Mariano canchuli ihr angetan hat eins
ist klar Leonarda wird keine glückliche
Kindheit haben absolut nicht zweimal
versucht Leonarda sich das Leben zu
nehmen das erste mal da ist sie gerade
13 Jahre alt sie überlebt beide Male
erst mit 23 Jahren scheint sich ihr
Leben zum Besseren zu wenden
Leonarda ist verliebt 1917 heiratet sie
raapaele panzardi raapaele ist beim
Grundbuchamt der Stadt eingestellt ein
kleiner Beamter nicht gerade eine gute
Partie so sieht es zumindest ihre Mutter
und verflucht die Ehe und ihre Tochter
ein Leben in Leid soll sie führen ich
sag mal so ihre Mutter hat bisher schon
alles getan um diesen Fluch wahrwererden
zu lassen aber für Leonarda ist das noch
mal eine ordentliche Schippe oben drauf
denn sie ist tief gläubig und tief
abergläubisch und so ein Fluch noch dazu
von der eigenen Mutter das ist schon
echt eine große Nummer das nimmt man
nicht so einfach auf die leichte
Schulter auf keinen Fall wobei es an der
Stelle vielleicht noch mal ganz gut ist
darauf hinzuweisen dass wir hier auf
leonardas eigene Aussagen in ihrer
Autobiografie angewiesen sind es ist
nicht auszuschließen dass sie diese
ganze Sache mit dem aber glauben
vielleicht auch als Entschuldigung
vorgeschoben hat ich denke hier können
wir ihr schon Vertrauen das war damals
nun weiß Gott nichts
Ungewöhnliches Leonarda geht irgendwann
in dieser Zeit auch zu einer Wahrsagerin
und die verspricht ihr ein langes Leben
ist doch gut voller Leiden ja nicht gut
und dass sie im Gefängnis und in der
Psychiatrie landen würde absolut gar
nicht gut aber auch dass sie viele
Kinder haben würde das wiederum ist sehr
gut Leonarda wünscht sich ja eine große
Familie und dass sie all ihre Kinder
überleben und zu Grabe tragen
wird okay Stopp stell dir vor du machst
ein Glückskeks auf und auf dem Zettel
steht sowas also wenn ich mir aus der
Hand lesen lasse oder so dann will ich
gefälligst hören dass alles gut wird und
ich ein super tolles Leben vor mir habe
na ja ich denke mal das wollte Leonarda
sicher auch aber im Gegensatz zu dir
glaubt sie an wahsagerei und Flüche und
all den möglichen okkulten Hokuspokus
und deshalb muss sie das wirklich schwer
getroffen haben ja zumal es so aussieht
als würde der Fluch der Mutter wirken
und als hätte die Wahrsagerin die
Wahrheit gesagt drei Kinder werden
totgeboren zehn sterben noch im
Säuglings oder Kleinkindalter warte zehn
zehn Kinder insgesamt wird Leonarda 17
Mal schwanger die letzten vier Kinder
überleben laut Leonarda mit Hilfe einer
örtlichen Zauber
na ja also eine gute hebarme und ein
Krankenhaus mit voll ausgestatteter
Neonatologie wären vermutlich effektiver
gewesen aber ja wir sind in der ersten
Hälfte des 20 Jahrhunderts in Italien
und nicht gerade wohlhabenden
Verhältnissen die vier Überlebenden
Kinder werden ihr ein und alles in ihren
Memoiren schreibt Leonarda fast jede
Nacht träumte ich von den kleinen weißen
Särgen die einer nach dem anderen von
der schwarzen Erde verschluckt wurden
deshalb habe ich Magie studiert ich habe
Bücher über Handlesen Astrologie
Beschwörungen Verhexungen Spiritismus
gelesen ich wollte alles darüber lernen
Zaubersprüche um sie eben neutralisieren
zu können 1930 zerstört ein Erdbeben das
Haus der Familien Lauria einem kleinen
Dorf in der Nähe von Coro ein weiterer
von zahllosen
Schicksalsschlägen allerdings nutzt
Leonarda diese Katastrophe um ihr
Schicksal zu wenden die Familie zieht
nach corio um und erhält eine
Entschädigung und Leonarda die aus Angst
um ihre Kinder so viel über Zauberei und
Wahrsagerei gelernt hat die gründet ihr
eigenes Startup für handleserei
Astrologie und nicht näher spezifizierte
[Musik]
Dienstleistungen schöne Umschreibung sie
verkauft auch Möbel Kleidung und Seife
aus eigener Herstellung oh oh na na nixx
oh oh bis hierhin ist erstmal alles
vollkommen in Ordnung das Geschäft ist
zwar klein aber es läuft und hilft der
Familie über die Runden denn rafaeles
Gehalt beim Amt ist na nicht gerade
üppig und dann
1939 bricht der Zweite Weltkrieg aus
Italien das vom faschistischen Diktator
Mussolini regiert wird steht an der
Seite Deutschlands
1940 soll leonardas Lieblingssohn
Giuseppe der zu diesem Zeitpunkt
studiert ein Beruf und an die Front
geschickt werden das ist glaube ich für
jede Mutter ein Schock für Leonarda
scheint es als wolle die Vorhersehung
sich nun ihr nächstes Kind holen das
Kind das sie am meisten liebt und
abgöttisch verehrt die Lösung liegt auf
der Hand na ja zumindest aus leonardas
Sicht sie muss dem Schicksal einen
Tausch anbieten ein anderer Mensch muss
sterben damit giseppe leben kann und so
plant sie auf wirklich kranke Weise ein
erstes
[Musik]
Menschenopfer forstina hat noch nicht
aufgegeben 70 Jahre ist sie alt und
glaubt immer noch an die Liebe mit 17
hat es nicht geklappt warum sollte es
nicht mit 70 klappen man ist nie zu alt
für lamore und tatsächlich stehen die
Sterne günstig das versichert ihr
zumindest ihre gute Freundin Leonarda
und die kennt sich mit sowas aus und sie
hat nicht nur in die Sterne geschaut sie
hat sogar schon einen passenden Mann
gefunden dummerweise lebt er im heutigen
Kroatien heißt sie können sich nicht mal
eben auf einen Kaffee verabreden aber
Faustina vertraut Leonarda die kennt ihn
nämlich persönlich und kann für ihn BGen
und ach er schreibt ihr sogar einen
Brief und lädt sie zu sich ein Leonarda
wird alles organisieren und Faustina
händigt ihr dankbar ihre gesamten
warnisse aus schließlich wird sie bald
einen gut situierten älteren Herren
heiraten der für ihren Lebensunterhalt
aufkommt am Tag vor der Abreise besucht
sie Leonarda noch einmal Leonarda rätt
ihr all ihren Bekannten zu schreiben
sobald sie in Kroatien angekommen ist
damit sich niemand über ihr plötzliches
Verschwinden wundert da Faustina
analphabeen ist schreibt Leonarda die
Briefe für sie dann reicht sie ein Glas
Wein und Faustina trinkt auf das späte
Liebesglück natürlich gibt es keinen
Mann in Kroatien der auf forustina
wartet stattdessen gibt es vergifteten
Wein und eine Axt als das Gift wirkt und
frustina sich nicht mehr bewegen oder
schreien kann da schlägt Leonarda zu
dreimal muss sie mit dem Beil auf die
wehrlose einhacken bis sie endlich
stirbt dann zerteilt sie den Körper mit
der Axt in neun Stücke und dann beginnt
der wirklich makabere Teil lass wir am
besten Leonarda selbst erzählen in ihren
Memoiren schreibt sie ich warf die
Stücke in einen bottig und fügte 7 Kil
etnatron hinzu die hatte ich gekauft um
Seife zu machen anschließend rührte ich
bis ich eine dunkle dickflüssige Masse
hatte die ich in mehrere Eimer verteilte
den Rest lehte ich in eine
Jauchegrube ich wartete bis das Blut
geronnen war dann trocknete ich es im
Ofen malte es und vermischte es
anschließend mit Mehl Zucker Schokolade
Milch Eiern und ein bisschen
Margarine daraus machte ich jede Menge
knusprige Kekse die ich an meine Gäste
und Besucher verteilte aber giseppe und
ich haben auch davon
gegessen tja die seifenmacherin von
coregio so wird man sie später nennen ja
die plätzchenbäckerin von corio hätte
auch gepasst irre oder was ich so krass
finde ist dass sie da einen Haufen Leute
unwissentlich zu Kannibalen gemacht hat
da nimmst du von so einer freundlichen
Dame ein Keks an schwups bistte
Menschenfresser na ein unschöner Gedanke
ein wirklich unschöner Gedanke ja wobei
ich mich frage also ich hoffe das klingt
jetzt nicht so despektierlich aber ich
meine das ist Italien das sind alles
Katholiken Blut und Kekse sind da
eigentlich nicht so ein Big Deal die
gibt's jeden Sonntag nur halt nicht in
der
mische ai die heilige Kommunion Leib und
Blut Christi und so na ja da begeben wir
uns auf wirklich ganz dünnes Eis Tony
vielleicht machen wir lieber mit
Leonarda weiter ja gute Idee denn
Leonarda die macht auch weiter im
September 1940 verspricht sie eine
älteren und von Geldsorgen geplagten
Lehrerin sie könne ihr eine gut bezahlte
Stelle als Leiterin einer Mädchenschule
in einer anderen Stadt vermitteln auch
die Lehrerin schreibt auf leonardas
Geheiß Briefe an alle bekannten und auch
sie bekommt einen Wein und ihr ahnt es
auch sie endet in einer
Keksdose
Tony ja sorry ich weiß das ist alles gar
nicht lustig aber dieser Story ist
absurd Leonarda tötet sie mit der Axt
vererteilt sie kocht sie und na ja was
soll ich sagen etwas von ihr landet
wirklich in der Keksdose wobei wir nicht
wissen ob es eine Keksdose oder ein
Keksteller oder was auch immer war aber
ach das wir doch langsam bisschen zu
makaber ja wenn es Euch liebe
Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer auch so geht
dann schaltet ihr jetzt besser schnell
ab oder switcht in irgendeiner anderen
Folge denn es geht tatsächlich noch
fieser kurze Zeit später sucht Virginia
kopo bei Leonarda nach Rat die
sopransängerin war einmal eine
Berühmtheit in der Gegend sie sang Opern
und das Publikum liebte sie aber das
liegt lange zurück natürlich hat
Leonarda gute Nachrichten für Sie in
Florenz gebe es einen reichen
theateragenten der sie liebend gern als
seine rechte Hand anheuern würde ja ihr
ahnt worauf es hinausläuft Leonarda
überzeugt die ahnungslose Virginia alle
Vorbereitungen zur Abreise geheim zu
halten ihr selbst eine beträchtliche
Geldsumme anzuvertrauen und vor der
Abreise auf einen letzten Wein
vorbeizukommen einen allerletzten Wein
sie stirbt unter leonardas axtheben was
dann folgt beschreibt Leonarda in ihrer
Autobiographie so
sie endete im Topf wie die anderen zwei
auch aber ihr Fleisch war fett und weiß
als sich alles aufgelöst hatte fügte ich
eine Flasche Parfüm hinzu und kochte sie
lange Zeit bis ich eine sehr cremige
Seife erhalten hatte ich verteilte
Seifenstücke als Geschenk an Nachbarn
und Bekannte auch die Süßigkeiten gelang
besser die Frau war wirklich
[Musik]
süß drei Frauen werden inhalb kurzer
Zeit zum Opfer der seifmacherin von Coro
dann wird sie gefasst ihre Opfer sind
als vermisst gemeldet worden die
Schwester des letzten Opfers der
Opernsängerin weiß zudem dass ihre
Schwester Virginia Leonarda chanchuli
vor ihrem Verschwinden besuchen wollte
und es gibt Hinweise aus der
Nachbarschaft dass Leonarda offenbar
plötzlich zu Geld zu viel Geld gekommen
sei Klassiker Verbrecher die geschnappt
werden weil sie ihr gestohlenes Geld
verbracht
auf leonardas Konto werden größere
Zahlungseingänge der Frauen entdeckt
daraufhin wird Ihre Wohnung durchsucht
und man findet den Schmuck ihres letzten
Opfers Leonarda canchuli wird verhaftet
doch die Polizei glaubt nicht dass sie
die alleinige Täterin ist jemand muss
ihr geholfen haben und vielleicht sogar
der Haupttäter gewesen sein niemals
könnte diese Mittelalter und harmlos
wirkende Frau in so kurzer Zeit wie sie
behauptet einen Menschen Z haacken ja
und sie verhaften auch ihren
Lieblingssohn giseppe den sie ja eben
vor dem Krieg retten wollte und nun ins
Gefängnis gebracht hat und so gesteht
sie alles in aller Ausführlichkeit um
abermals ihren Sohn zu schützen doch die
Ermittler glauben ihr kein Wort bis okay
das ist dann jetzt wohl vielleicht der
makabere Höhepunkt des ganzen wenn es
denn stimmt wir haben mehrere Quellen
dafür gefunden aber keine die wirklich
hundertprozentig verlässlich ist aber
verdammt es passt einfach zu gut zu der
ganzen Geschichte Leonarda chanchuli
lässt sich in eine Leichenhalle führen
und zerhackt vor den Augen der stauenden
Beamten eine nicht identifizierte Leiche
und zwar fachgerecht und
topfgerecht das alles in wenigen
Minuten ob das nun genauso passiert ist
oder nicht tatsache ist dass man ihr
glaubt Giuseppe kommt frei Leon sitzt in
Untersuchungshaft der Krieg verzögert
einen Prozess bis sie
1946 schließlich zu 30 Jahren Haft und
anschließend in 3 Jahren Unterbringung
in der Psychiatrie verurteilt wird also
genau das was die Wahrsagerin ihr
angekündigt hatte genau das eigentlich
hat alles gestimmt das Leben voller
Leiden das Gefängnis dass sie ihre
Kinder überleben würde nicht alle aber
13 von 17 ja da war schon einiges dran
gut geraten und ziemlich fies würde ich
sagen aber wie gesagt Leonarda glaubte
an Magie und war sagerei okay Tony eine
Sache schwirt mir gerade noch im Kopf
rum wenn sie eigentlich mit einem
Menschenopfer ihren Giuseppe vor dem Tod
retten wollte warum hat sie dann drei
Frauen umgebracht das ist eine sehr gute
Frage das habe ich mich auch gefragt
vielleicht wollte sie für ihre anderen
Kinder auch noch so eine ja Art na ja
nennen wir es Versicherung abschließen
oder sie war der Meinung dass drei alte
Damen ein guter Tausch für das Leben
eines jungen Mannes sind man weiß es
nicht ja keine Ahnung wie das karmamäßig
umgerechnet wird es gibt aber noch eine
dritte Erklärung nämlich dass Leonarda
schlicht und einfach gierig war oder es
nach dem geglückten ersten Mord wurde
sie selbst beharte immer darauf dass sie
nur aus Liebe gemordet habe und so
schreibt sie es auch in ihrer
Autobiografie aber ich weiß nicht gear
hat zumindest eine Rolle gespielt sonst
hätte sie die Opfer wohl nicht auch noch
so schamlos ausgenommen und danach eben
mit ihrem neuen Wohlstand geprotzt die
Prophezeiung dass sie nicht nur im
Gefängnis sondern auch in der
Psychiatrie landen würde erfüllte sich
übrigens nicht Leonarda chanchuli starb
nachdem sie 24 ihre 30 Jahre Haft
abgesessen hatte 1970 in einem
italienischen
Gefängnis boah das war echt ein ein sehr
sehr krasser Fall
ich würde sagen m und damit beenden wir
auch die heutige Folge das war lich mehr
als genug ich will nicht sagen das muss
ich erstmal verdauen da gebe ich dir auf
jeden Fall recht wir sind am Ende
unserer heutigen Episode und bedanken
uns dass ihr mit dabei wart die heutige
Erzählung stammt unter anderem von
Beiträgen auf
museoriminologiko IT
allthinteresting.com und Auszügen aus
leonardas Autobiografie Geständnisse
einer verbitterten Seele danke fürs
zuhören und nehmt euch keinen Keks macht
einen ganz großen bogendum zumindest für
heute
bis zum nächsten mal eure Tony und euer
Mirko ciao
ciao die hat diese Folge von Tatort
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere weiteren Folgen rein
hier warten mehr als 200 spannende Fälle
auf dich wie das Verschwinden von
Rebecca Reusch der Prozess gegen OJ
Simpson oder die Entführung von ursela
Hermann wir hören uns bei tatout
Deutschland